Authority looks good on you jimmy where's
darcy we can thank her for that captain
rambeau they're asking for you in the theater
i was sent by an old friend of your mother's
he'd like to meet with you
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision post credit scene for monica rambeau
captain marvel 2 and all the other nick fury's
stuff that they were setting up so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll be
doing falcon and winter soldier episodes starting
next and then we'll get the loki episode so i'll
be doing videos for all that stuff this year but
careful for spoilers for everything that happened
on Wandavision if you have not seen the episodes
yet so i'll just start at the beginning of this
also explain some of the deleted storylines we
just learned about a bunch of stuff that they had
to cut from the series so if it felt like they
were missing things or there were hanging plot
threads or if there was too much stuff that they
didn't explain during the last couple of episodes
it's for a very good reason it's because
they deleted a lot of footage that they shot
but we start with monica rambeau saying goodbye to
scarlet witch as she flies off with the dark hold
to head to the wundegor mountains to learn what
it says about her the prophecy that she's supposed
to destroy the world with her chaos magic i've
already done a video about that so i'll link it
at the end of this but you do remember that at
this point when she's saying goodbye to monica
rambeau she doesn't know about billy and tommy
yet that doesn't happen till the time jump later
when she's actually studying the darkhold but
then monica walks over to congratulate jimmy
woo on taking control of the cleanup effort in
town with the fbi there was actually a writer on
twitter after i think it was episode 5 had aired a
couple weeks ago who said that marvel had actually
invited him to pitch a jimmy woo marvel spin-off
series for disney plus like agents of atlas or
something like that like make it x-files in the
mcu with jimmy woo and darcy doing the mulder
and skully thing just investigating similar
types of events as wanda and the hex in the mcu
no idea if that'll wind up happening but it's just
a good example of marvel recognizing how popular
characters come up that they didn't expect to
be popular and like okay if people like this
we'll give them more of this character kevin feige
didn't specifically say what their plans were for
jimmy after Wandavision but i'm also assuming that
he'll cameo again during ant-man 3 quantum mania
because he's from the san francisco area to begin
with so he has a connection with those characters
but on top of that everyone loved his character so
much he became such a big thing during the run of
the show that 100 percent for sure i'm expecting
we're going to see a bunch of him in the next
several years popping up all over the place early
prediction even if that jimmy woo spin-off series
doesn't wind up happening he'll still become like
the new version of coulson like a colson type
character who just shows up all the time in weird
places throughout the movies in disney plus series
just adding some connective tissue linking
things together providing some more continuity
and each time he shows up he's just a little bit
better at close-up magic until he's able to pull
off some really badass save or a takedown in some
future movie i don't know if he's supposed to show
up in shang chin the legend of the ten rings but a
big part of that movie also takes place in the san
francisco area where the events of ant-man and the
wasp took place so jimmy woo would also be nearby
it's pretty easy to explain his presence and why
he could show up in that movie probably not going
to get a trailer for that until the black widow
movie comes out but i'll do separate videos about
the movies when they give us updates about that
but then they explained what happened to darcy
after she took down tyler heyward and just laugh
about him getting carted off in handcuffs no idea
if we're going to see tyler heyward again i don't
know if they plan on bringing that character back
anybody who's not dead and locked up in prison
could always come back as part of all the deleted
scenes we actually found out that there was a
big storyline and a lot more stuff with sword in
the real world scenes that they had to get rid of
just because they didn't have time to finish them
so as with a lot of things this year just blame
the virus and the slowdown for them having to get
rid of that stuff so it sounds like he was a much
more interesting character before they had to get
rid of those scenes but if you're wondering
why darcy only had that one short scene in
the finale and didn't come back after that it's
because she was part of this alternate storyline
involving evan peters senior scratchy the dark
hold in monica rambeau that they just had to get
rid of like a really big action scene that they
didn't have time to finish the special effects for
i'll include that when i do my deleted scenes
video later this week but just for reference
it doesn't involve quicksilver really being
quicksilver he was always going to be that
ralph character i'll explain that during the video
later this week but if you're wondering that also
explains why it felt like monica rambeau didn't
do a whole lot during the finale just because
most of those were deleted scenes but then another
fbi agent walks in and tells monica rambeau that
they want a debriefer in the movie theater in
the marquis reads the tannhauser gate put the
fun in dysfunction that's mostly a reference
to the blade runner movie it's a line quoted by
roy batty the replicant deckard is hunting down
talking about all the wondrous adventures he's
had in outer space things that he saw during
his lifespan that will be lost when he dies i've
seen things attack ships on
fire off the shoulder of orion
i watched sea beams glitter in the dark near the tannhauser gate. So the tannhauser gate was just
one of the amazing things that he saw but the way
they're using it in the episode in the context
of the episode monica rambeau walking into the
theater with that above is mostly a reference to
the future adventures that she's going to have in
outer space with nick fury and then in the captain
marvel 2 movie i also think that they have more
planned for her character based on the way the
rest of that scene plays out too so as she walks
into the theater the agent reveals herself as a
scroll who's working with nick fury an old friend
of her mother's heard she was grounded and wants
to meet her in space as she points up even if you
don't remember the plot of all the marvel movies
i feel like everybody knew that that was nick fury
her being grounded was just a call back to episode
4 when she was blipped back and tyler heyward
claimed that her mother had a special protocol
for grounding sword astronauts who were blip back
after the snap in avengers infinity war now it's
possible that that could have been a lie since
tyler heyward seems like he lied about almost
everything during the series almost everything
he was telling the truth about the reason
sword pivoted to developing sentient weapons
like i said there were a lot of deleted scenes
for the sword stuff taking place while the hex
stuff was going on that provided more context
for what sword was doing and what other stuff
had been happening for the past five years that
they just had to get rid of because of the virus
slowdown but here's the thing about that moment
where she tells monica that she's going up
to nick fury's space station to meet him
you have to remember that the events of
Wandavision take place three weeks after avengers
end game pretty close also around the same time
span when falcon and winter soldier take place
so all the stuff with falcon and winter soldier
is happening almost at the same time that all the
stuff with the Wandavision is happening i'll talk
about that more when we get to the falcon winter
soldier episodes in a couple weeks that's starting
literally next week but Wandavision takes place
three weeks after avengers end game the events of
spider-man far from home where we last saw that
space station with nick fury that's eight months
after avengers end game so when we saw nick fury
getting the message from talos he's probably
already had that meeting with monica rambeau
and here's another important detail there's going
to be the nick fury avengers secret invasion
disney plus series next year that will take place
probably before the events of the captain marvel 2
movie so while we know that monica rambeau
and nick fury are going to come back in
captain marvel 2 i also think that the stuff he
wanted to talk to her about about ungrounding her
involves some of the plot of the secret invasion
series now the way that kevin feige pitched that
series last year talos and nick fury are the
two main characters and they're playing it more
like the american series on fx like more of the
political intrigue and paranoia aspects of the
secret invasion comic book story line so they're
not going to be doing the full blown every single
avengers character as a scroll like they did in
the comics it won't be quite as crazy as the comic
book storyline the same way that they adapted the
house of m storyline for Wandavision but only did
some of the aspects of that story in some of the
easter eggs so monica rambeau might also show
up during secret invasion i don't know if she's
meant to be a big character during that but i'm
just expecting maybe some light easter eggs to
provide some more continuity because so much of
that is tied to captain marvel 2 but talking about
her powers and her future as the photon character
they showed you a little more of her abilities
during the finale with her phasing those bullets
using a combination of different powers i did a
huge video for monica rambeau and her powers so
i'll put a link for that in the description but
what's happening here is her body is basically
made of light so she can phase stuff just like
vision phases stuff even though she's doing it
in a slightly different way but she can also
manipulate and replicate all forms of energy
so she's also absorbing the kinetic energy of the
bullets which is why they slow down like that when
they're phasing through her body she can also do
that with any kind of energy any kind of energy
but in order to do it she has to be able to
understand how new forms of energy work which
just takes a lot of time and practice which is why
she can't just do it on the spot for example given
enough time she could also probably manipulate
wanda's chaos magic energy if she could understand
it now that's crazy complex like she could also
manipulate infinity stone energy given enough time
that's why she's one of the most powerful
characters in the mcu but it just depends on
who's writing her and how they write the character
she can also turn into pure light and then fly
at the speed of light but those are all god tier
abilities that they'll probably save for some of
the movies and future sequels wherever they want
the character to show up so it's not like they
introduce the character and then five seconds
later she goes god tear but she has all those
abilities right now she just needs to learn how
to use them is the same thing with thor and thor
ragnarok like he was always that powerful he just
needed to learn how his powers worked in a more
fundamental way so when she comes back in captain
marvel 2 she'll probably get a full-blown photon
comic book costume and learn a couple new powers
from the comics and i say she'll probably go with
the photon name even though she's had many comic
book names like she's the original female version
of captain marvel in the comics she was captain
marvel before carol danvers became captain marvel
but she'll probably go with the photon name just
because her mother's call sign in the air force
was photon as for the drama that they teased that
she has going on with captain marvel the character
back in episode five i think that probably just
has something to do with her not being around when
she was growing up or not coming back to help her
mother when she died but they probably will wait
to the events of the captain marvel 2 movie to
address what's going on with that it just they'll
have some big beef that they'll work out during
the movie hopefully they'll trade some blows
because now monica can be just as powerful as
captain marvel it just depends on how they write
the characters though like i said technically
monica rambeau should be more powerful in the
comics but they might not necessarily go that
direction for the movies but if you spotted any
other big easter eggs during that monica rambeau
post-credits scene that i didn't talk about during
the video just write them below in the comments
and what will happen later this week is i'll do
the video for the Wandavision alternate ending and
deleted scenes and there's a bunch of new falcon
and winter soldier trailers that i'll do videos
for and new justice league snyder cut trailers so
in addition to falcon and winter soldier episodes
there is a bunch of big stuff happening in the
next couple of weeks make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any of
that stuff while you wait for everything everyone
click here for that other Wandavision post credit
scene with the doctor strange 2 teaser and
click here for my full Wandavision episode
9 finale video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!